[Applaus]
[Musik]
japan ein land das auf zwei dinge
besonders stolz ist das erste sind
automaten für getragene unterwäsche die
dort einfach so an gehwegen rumstehen
und das zweite ist einwanderungs quote
die bei weitem die niedrigste alle
industrienationen ist um einen vergleich
zu ziehen
in amerika stieg die zahl im ausland
geborene einwohner gerade auf 13 prozent
in deutschland beträgt sie 16 prozent
und in kanada und neuseeland sind es
sogar 20 bis 25 prozent
in japan hingegen hatte ich fest sind es
weniger als zwei prozent
der grund das restriktive
einwanderungsland der träume für
politiker wie donald trump oder marine
le pen
sucht man nach einem thema das die
aktuelle politische debatte besonders
stark trägt dann ist dies sicher
migration in europa streiten sich die
länder darüber was mit den flüchtlingen
geschehen soll
und es scheint so als ob die meisten
politiker der meinung sein dass
einwanderung ein problem ist welches
unbedingt gestoppt werden muss japan ist
das perfekte beispiel dafür was es
bedeutet in einem land ohne einwanderer
zu leben und jetzt fragt ihr euch
vielleicht welche auswirkungen dies auf
die wirtschaft haben sparen die japaner
wirklich geld damit dass sie nichts in
die sozialpolitik für die neuankömmlinge
investieren müssen führen japanische
arbeiter ein besseres leben da sie nicht
mit ausländischen arbeitskräften
konkurrieren müssen heute werden wir all
diese fragen beantworten aber vorher
schauen wir uns mal kurz die japanischen
einwanderungsgesetze an
[Musik]
eine kultur eine rasse dieses zitat
stammt von yasujiro nakasone den mann
der mitte der 80er jahre premierminister
von japan war es bringt die grundsätze
der einwanderungspolitik dieses landes
auf den punkt grundsätzlich gibt es nur
zwei möglichkeiten ins land der
aufgehenden sonne zu gelangen
die erste ist mit einem arbeitsvertrag
die andere mit einem touristenvisum wenn
eine firma euch im ausland einstellen
möchte benötigt ihr trotzdem ein visum
und die einzige möglichkeit ein visum zu
erhalten ist ein universitätsabschluss
oder spezifische fähigkeiten die auf den
japanischen arbeitsmarkt praktisch nicht
zu finden sind
also wenn ihr beispielsweise nur einen
bauarbeiter seid werdet ihr diese
arbeitserlaubnis nie bekommen es sei
denn ihr benutzt ein anderes programm
wie ein karton kommen
da japan kein gesetz hatte um arbeiter
aus anderen asiatischen ländern wie zb
vietnam oder den philippinen aufzunehmen
haben sie das so genannte tecnico
internen training program ins leben
gerufen
das bedeutet so was die ein akt i can't
in japan zu sein allerdings nur bei
halbem gehalt eines japanischen
praktikanten aber das ist noch nicht
alles mit diesem technical internen
training program darf euer chef euren
pass einziehen und sogar zugriff auf
euer bankkonto einfordern
und noch schlimmer seitdem dieses
programm an schließend tausende von
asiatischen einwanderern einfach
verschwunden als die vertreterin der
gewerkschaft mit mir sprach sagte sie
mir dass meine einstellung schlecht sei
und wenn ich diese haltung beibehalten
wenn ich mich weiter so verhielte würde
ihr freund ein killer einstellen um mich
zu töten
aber was wenn ihr mit einem
touristenvisum eingereist nun in diesem
fall könnte er anderthalb jahre im land
bleiben solange ihnen nachweisen könnte
dass ihr japanische lernt nach ablauf
dieser zeit müssen wir von einem
unternehmen eingestellt werden und dann
könnt ihr ein arbeits visum bekommen
aber vorsicht im gegensatz zu anderen
orten die amerika oder der europäischen
union ist das japanische arbeitsvisum an
den beruf gebunden
das bedeutet wenn ihr eine
arbeitserlaubnis als koch habt dürft in
einem restaurant nicht einfach so als
kellner arbeiten sondern nur als koch
andernfalls wird die genehmigung nicht
erneuert so gesehen gibt es nur einen
sicheren weg um in japan leben zu können
thomas balcerowski der einfachste weg um
hier zu leben ist ein japaner zur heirat
wohnung jetzt versteht ihr wie es
möglich ist dass ein land mit über 127
millionen einwohnern nur zwei millionen
einwanderer hat ist lass uns mal sehen
welche auswirkungen dies auf das
tägliche leben der japanischen bürger
hat
[Musik]
wer bezahlt die japanischen renten
kapern ist das älteste land der welt
dies liegt nicht an seine geschichte
sondern am durchschnittsalter der
japanischen bevölkerung schätzungen
zufolge werden dort in 90 jahren über 44
millionen einwohner weniger leben als
heute
was der gesamten heutigen bevölkerung
kann das entspricht
[Musik]
eines der größten probleme dass sich
daraus ergibt hängt mit dem sozialsystem
zusammen wie ihr wahrscheinlich wisst
funktioniert das rentensystem in den
meisten ländern so die menschen die
heute arbeiten sind diejenigen die die
rente diejenigen zahlen die in diesem
moment im ruhestand sind mit die zahl
der arbeitskräfte von jahr zu jahr ab
gibt es immer weniger menschen die die
rentenbeiträge zahlen und gleichzeitig
immer mehr rentner ihren lebensunterhalt
durch die beitragszahler gestritten
werden muss und daher sind solche dinge
geschehen die
[Musik]
sozialversicherungsbeiträge decken nur
60 prozent dieser leistungen ab die
restlichen 40 millionen stammen aus
steuergeldern
genauer gesagt aus haushaltsdefiziten
[Musik]
auch wenn dich
sozialversicherungsbeiträge von jahr zu
jahr steigen würden kann japan die
rentenzahlung im endeffekt nicht
nachhaltig finanzieren eigentlich nicht
einmal die sozialausgaben
woher nimmt japan also das geld dafür
passt auf japans staatsverschuldung ist
die höchste aller staaten der welt sie
entspricht mehr als dem doppelten ihres
bruttoinlandsprodukts das
haushaltsdefizit das heißt die differenz
zwischen einnahmen und ausgaben ist
sogar höher als in spanien oder anders
gesagt ein wolfgang schäuble müsste dort
als finanzminister wohl ausrasten und
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht was das
alles mit einwanderung zu tun hat nun
die antwort lautet eine ganze menge
schaut mal wir alle haben davon gehört
wie teuer es ist ein wanderer zu
integrieren muss sozialprogramme
integrationskurse und alle anderen
möglichen ausgaben finanzieren aber
keiner spricht darüber wie viel ein
normaler einheimischen bürger den staat
punkten
zum beispiel kostet ein in amerika
geborene bürger die staat also die
allgemeinheit vor seiner geburt bis zum
sechzehnten lebensjahr durchschnittlich
150.000 us dollar
und hier sind nur bildung und
gesundheitsversorgung mit einbezogen und
ausstellungen können noch weitere
ausgaben dazu kommen dieses geld ist
eine investition und der staat wird die
gegenleistung für diese investition von
dem tag an zurückfordern an dem der
bürger anfängt zu arbeiten zum
steuerzahlen erstellt euch im gegenzug
einen vietnamesischen immigranten vor
er kommt in das land will alt genug ist
um zu arbeiten
die kosten seiner ausbildung und
gesundheitsversorgung bis dahin wurden
von der vietnamesischen allgemeinheit
getragen
[Musik]
im schnitt wird der in zwei jahren einen
job finden
und natürlich kann es sein dass dieser
job schlecht bezahlt ist und deshalb
wird ein wenige steuerzahler aber die
japanische regierung musste ja kaum geld
investieren mit anderen worten ein
wanderer können im grunde eine super
einnahmequelle für einen start sein wenn
es richtig gemacht aber da japan nun mal
keine einwanderung zulässt verpasst es
diese gelegenheit den ställen zu machen
deshalb hat der japanische
premierminister shinzo abe mitten in der
finanzkrise im jahr 2015
die folgende ankündigung gemacht japan
steht unter druck mehr einwanderer
aufzunehmen da die erwerbsbevölkerung
schrumpft aber nicht so schnell
obwohl es so scheint ist dies nicht
japans größtes problem
tatsächlich hat dieses land seit 20
jahren kein richtiges
wirtschaftswachstum mehr vorzuweisen
experten nennen es das verlorene
jahrzehnt und in dieser angelegenheit
spiel auch die einwanderer eine große
rolle
[Musik]
das land das mit der innovation
aufgehört hat sie alle stellen und japan
als das land der technik und innovation
vor das land aus dem unternehmen wie
nintendo sony oder toshiba corp
[Applaus]
allerdings sind all diese unternehmen
alt intenso wurde 1889 gegründet toyota
1937 und kann einer von euch sage mal
fünf japanische unternehmen nennen die
erst im 21ten jahrhundert gegründet
wurden sowie tesla oder facebook in den
usa wahrscheinlich nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
immigranten haben 52 prozent aller neuen
unternehmen im silicon valley zwischen
den jahren 1995 und 2005 gegründet die
unternehmer quote unter einwanderern ist
zwei- oder dreimal so hoch die unter
einheimischen und diesen trend findet
man in jedem land so wurde
beispielsweise einer der gründer von
google sängerin in moskau geboren der
mitbegründer von whatsapp janko stammt
aus der ukraine
[Musik]
aber das betrifft nicht bewusste liegt
in willich start ups macht einfach mal
einen spaziergang in ihrer nachbarschaft
und ihr werdet hunderte von geschäften
restaurants und anderen arten von
kleinunternehmen sehen die von der
kranken gegründet wurden es macht
absolut sinn dass einwanderer diesen
unternehmerischen geist haben es endlich
sind menschen die sich aufmachen irland
um ihre vertraute umgebung zu verlassen
ksc risiko affiner als jene die einfach
nur daheim bleiben und nicht nur das ein
immigrant bringt eine andere kultur mit
die es ihm leichter macht über den
tellerrand hinauszuschauen
[Applaus]
heute ein beispiel haas feldmann ein
deutscher einwanderer der in losen
jahrhundert nach new york city kam schon
bald erkannte er dass die vielen
menschen der enormen stadt mit ihrem
schnellen spiel etwas zu essen brauchten
dass man leicht auf der straße zu
bereiten herumtragen unter gleich aus
der hand verspeisen konnte aus diesem
grund beschloss er jene frankfurter
würstchen der aus seiner heimat kannte
in typisch amerikanische weiche lange
weizenbrötchen so höhn
und so wurde der hotdog geboren heute
ernährt diese mahlzeit millionen von
menschen auf dem ganzen planeten ja ich
weiß dass das mein kleines beispiel ist
aber wenn ihr danach sucht werdet ihr
tausende und abertausende von
geschichten wie diese sind kurz gesagt
wenn sich kulturen mischen entstehen
neue ideen und methoden das nennen
geschäftsleute dann innovationen und
genau das ist die zutat die unternehmen
und ganze länder wachsen lässt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie geht es also weiter mit japan ist
überrascht nicht dass japan die
niedrigste unternehmer quote in der
industrialisierten welt hat nur sieben
prozent der bevölkerung entschied sich
für die gründung eines unternehmens
zum vergleich in kanada oder neuseeland
liegt der prozentsatz bei zehn prozent
der japanische traum besteht nicht darin
ein unternehmen zu gründen sondern er
frei von allen risiken von einem bereits
existierenden und gut etablierten
unternehmen eingestellt zu werden
ihr wisst schon jene großen unternehmen
wie sony oder toshiba die seit den 1980
er jahren praktisch die gleiche
unternehmensstruktur und die gleiche
arbeitskultur beibehalten haben
[Musik]
traditionelle japanische
elektronikkonzerne wie sharp und sony
haben enorme verluste erlitten und
tausende von arbeitsplätzen abgebaut
während die wettbewerber apple und
samsung ihre marktanteile weiter
ausgebaut haben der fußball markt
verfügt meist gebannt die europa- und
weltmeisterschaften
noch vor 20 jahren gab es mindestens
immer zwei japanische unternehmen
die als große sponsoren dieser
veranstaltung aufgetreten sind
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an das
ein oder andere von damals aber ab dem
jahr 2016 hatte die europameisterschaft
keinen einzigen japanischen sponsor mehr
und ganz egal wo man hinschaut
japanische unternehmen haben
schwierigkeiten mit europäischen
amerikanischen oder sogar chinesischen
unternehmens konkurrieren
der grund dafür ist nicht ein mangel an
geld sondern ein mangel an innovation
dies erklärt warum japans wirtschaft
seit zwei jahrzehnten wie eingefroren
wird
[Musik]
dies alles spiegelt sich natürlich auch
im leben von japans bürgern hier um ein
hohes produktivitätsniveau und damit
ihre wettbewerbsfähigkeit aufrecht
erhalten zu können müssen japanische
arbeitnehmer die längsten arbeitszeiten
und die kürzesten ferien aller oecd
länder auf sich nehmen wer sie für das
gleiche gehalt schuften müssen das auch
schon ihre eltern eine generation früher
erhalten
[Musik]
jetzt wollen wir eure meinung hören
glaubt ihr dass japan seine türen für
einwanderer öffnen sollte oder glaubt
ihr dass einwanderung ein problem
darstellt das unbedingt gestoppt werden
muss wir sind auf eure antworten in den
kommentaren gespannt bald werden wir ein
video rausbringen in dem erklärt wird
wie israel dank seiner einwanderer so
innovations- drehscheibe der welt
geworden ist wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen wollen vergesst nicht auf den
abo button zu klicken
und wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat
gibt uns einen daumen hoch
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]